[Music]
in DIY or Die news mmm
submitted by a 16 year old virgin sad
smile why is that a sign smiley normal
stay a virgin cool bro yeah you're fine
that's not bad way to go there people
would would double your life time and
they're still virgins still making a hit
and that's fine - okay - a nurse alone
in his clinic treated himself while
having a heart attack
that's gangsters [ __ ] that's like the
guy who started an alarm off on when he
got caught under the rock oh the
mountain climber right climber guy that
made a movie out of it yeah that's some
gang stuff - danda no [ __ ] no yeah the
pocket knife I'm crying and I would talk
about how life how God made life so hard
for me yeah I mean if you're already
down enough to go into the wilderness by
yourself that says a lot of yeah you're
already a crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] at
night oh my god come on yeah man yeah
that's it back did he get his limp back
no pocket knife and then he had to have
like broken like the leg with the rock
or something cuz right how do you break
you exactly I use that pocket knife to
do this you do a [ __ ] Conair kill
kill move and that movie would have been
so fast I got it you see the knife I
can't be too much of a [ __ ] to do that
I would just slowly go just let it bleed
out yeah you take four hours a night
you'd go oh four four and a half hours
yeah as it bear smell your blood there's
nurse here he was a nurse for one of
Australia's most remote corners that's
how you know they're tough because about
600 almost 600 miles away from Perth and
then almost a hundred miles away from
any hospital please [ __ ] I picture
Crocodile Dundee in a [ __ ] scrub
uniform to go with the smock I like it
almost that onesie that's not an office
is it not no that's a scalpel good very
good right I enjoy Airport is that you
yeah so this nurse 44 year old man he
experienced sudden dizziness
severe chest pain and so what what he
did is he hooked himself up to
electrical leads on his upper body and
then he recorded his heart rhythm on a
graph and then he send it over a via a
phone line boy that's not normal was he
in the hospital so he works at a clinic
but he was the only one working that
night and so any calm we did all this
should I'd be like oh I couldn't call
9-1-1 cuz he was the ninth one is he
hairless too you probably have to [ __ ]
your shave his chest here to put all
electrode here oh yeah what did they put
a shirt and he's like wait I don't have
to do that I can take my own about that
let's say that that's $40 I get to keep
I only think about that [ __ ] and doctor
shows stuff I'm like wow yeah they can't
wait that's a Tommy Bahama I honestly
feel like the extra two seconds they're
saving it's not gonna help much just
[ __ ] leave my clothes
well it's cuz they don't know every
paralyzed so they want to keep
everything intact didn't want you walk
out of a Tommy Bahama without spent at
least a hundred bucks come on Tommy
Bahama of the store men's older men's
with all the principal shopping yeah
guys guys who have heart attacks
clothing because they eat a lot of steak
dinners I never heard of that Tommy
Bahama really all the principles were
it's like the bun down shirt where the
sleeve goes off probably been inside or
seen it don't know the name you must not
know a lot of doing or companies if you
see this shirt you'll be like it so good
I'm not gonna wear that until I'm 50
thing and then you're like I'm trying to
distract from this so whatever I can
wear here like a stay there please yeah
dude your hands move very gracefully oh
thank you thank you and they're very
soft - would you like to feel them again
will you please to each other Magette
one more time wait no David taught me
some yeah you actually did it a lot
better this time
right he taught me as you taught me do
the counterclockwise or whatever yeah
you just have to keep your hand down
here pull my head up here [ __ ] spun
no I learned I learned keep it up here
sir defend your face even though it
doesn't look cool make sure to keep a
gap though just keep a gap he began
oh so you hit yourself in the face when
they punch you I'm not an idiot have
your [ __ ] knuckles directly at your
teeth like this when you fight wear a
lot of rings here
spiky rings we got your back totally I
mean watching me
he ended up recording his his heart
rhythm and all that like the test that
he ran on himself he did it twice
gave himself an echocardiogram you mean
yes oh you liar you know I already know
thank you from here I mean this thing my
eyes are not good
have you heard all right well you did do
an electric car Alecto glasses so
cardiogram can't is it that one no what
no that is a different defibrillation he
did prep himself though with the
defibrillator pads in case he did
somehow go out and link firt I like how
are you planning this like if your heart
stops how are you gonna do that on
yourself maybe he felt it coming
question what exactly is a heart attack
what happens one of his arteries got
clogged there was like I told you so
and the first graph that he sent over
they said like his arteries were just a
little bit clogged it wasn't super crazy
but then the first October the second
will Hannah you sent was completely
clogged so that means like you oh [ __ ]
yep oh [ __ ] me the only person to get
close to it I still attacks it because I
can't do it okay that's how they sound
very accurate is he fat get the base
down though I don't know I don't have a
photo it's just that's pretty crazy no
his story he's a gangster I feel like
sometimes I get so panicky and angry I'm
gonna get a heart attack my heart starts
beating his [ __ ] I feel like all
Austrians are this badass right if you
got deadly spiders dude we have to
[ __ ] deadly spiders deadly snakes
deadly burns deadly [ __ ] kangaroos
that kick you in the balls Sachs [ __ ]
man you get a heart attack if you just
start punching yourself in the chest
would it help
this is why we need a doctor here so we
can drive them mad and make them want to
leave how about just going to the local
Aborigine population and asking them for
their wisdom mystical ways to do revive
yourself with household items I just
think the didgeridoo is one of the best
instruments that was ever [ __ ] me
that's og Australia wow wow yeah it's
[ __ ] dope the didgeridoo the
didgeridoo
yeah but this thing this dude it's
really impressive because he put an IV
line on himself he gave himself a lot of
medications that the doctor was
prescribing cuz he was in communication
with the doctor even though he was all
alone but he was doing all this on
himself and then the the drug that he
took there's only a 50/50 chance that it
would work and luckily it did work
before he had to perform open-heart
surgery on himself
wham be man yeah like what do you do you
inject a journal into your head and your
arms so they can stay alive while your
body is numb or some [ __ ] I'm not even
fazed by the [ __ ] cuz I watched so many
action movies where Rambo got a [ __ ]
little bullet and he had to like have
some [ __ ] pull that [ __ ] bullet out
like I was a little bullet can you
imagine in the way he goes up to the
waiting room after hooking [ __ ] and
he's like I'll be with you in just a few
moments yeah it's like that fiction in
films that were they dig a bullet out of
[ __ ] [ __ ] Sylvester always has to dig
a bullet out for no reason I love in
movies when they pour alcohol like like
like like liquor on the world yeah they
got a rip a piece of their shirts I feel
like my luck as I'm doing this I'm
pulling it the [ __ ] the Rope [ __ ]
snaps and then nothing happens damn I
feel like God died from that infection
oh yeah for sure
pull that bullet out and then you're
like shooting up [ __ ] jungle enemies
and [ __ ] and then afterwards you get
can die what's the last time you guys
gave blood I never give that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that I'll give boy because they contract
you I don't do it cuz they can track you
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy I haven't had
one in a long ass a blood test my old
when a drop blood from you for do like
diagnostic source of all we did that the
amount of blood that squirts out is
[ __ ] like a Tarantino movie because
this [ __ ] didn't [ __ ] first of all I
will try not to laugh cuz she sound like
a swale of her family guys me Superman
all here well we're looking for a
missing the whole time she's like this
before no and I'd like like literally
I'm a compulsive try not to laugh but
she just sticks it as she goes it hurt
no all coming up it can be seem a lot
but very little
they're just squirting the [ __ ] out she
for the five vial yeah yeah yeah cuz I
like a [ __ ] fountain my uncle will
not give blood because he feels that
they can track you and I'm like you have
diabetes they already have your blood no
I study I think it started when they
gave him a Social Security right I mean
no I studied to be a phlebotomist a long
time ago and but when I had to do
drawers and everything drawers in the
biz that's cool
yeah just telephone oh yeah and then
there was this one lady because I I told
her like hey you know I I was letting
her know that I'm gonna I'm gonna suck
at this yeah like I'm learning so you
know just be patient with me and she was
so nervous and free stuff so like when I
poked her first of all she had really
hard veins was of my flowered veins like
no legs it's hard to find them right oh
yeah thick uh yeah she was on the
thicker side and so when when I poked
her prick Terry thank you lemonade when
I pricked her poker
definitely went through the veins and
then all of a sudden Oh her whole oh you
gave her a hematoma yeah I'm sorry
bruising Oh like two times I try to get
it that you do I got a hematoma on both
times never gave blood after that us
what do you do tip are you like this is
completely normal
no don't worry the first time I ever
ever gave blood was in high school and I
looked at the lady she was like I I
don't like needles and I'm doing this
because I really like this girl behind
me it should kind of like go to me into
doing it she goes sweetie I've done this
all day I haven't had a single mess-up
pop my whole arm starts turning purple I
like what is she goes I just gave you a
hematoma like what is that i pierce
through your vein and that's there's
gonna be a huge bruise and your arms
gonna be sore we can't do this poop and
then you just see your whole arm bruise
[ __ ] and it immediately and ours so it's
like why did you even go there today to
get a lolly otherwise just the best part
and they're like I'm sorry sir we only
give lobby a lot of lollies to the
donors oh they damn well gave me a
[ __ ] cookie because she's [ __ ]
stabbed that's better
thanks a lot TIFF
[Music]